hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well so Jeremy Bentham
starts off with this really famous
passage saying that mankind has two
masters hated pleasure and that not only
do these always motivate us in the last
analysis they walk to us so even saying
two different things it's Kenneth Clark
because of the rhetoric to see exactly
what he's doing he's saying that we are
the kind of beings that are motivated by
pain and pleasure that's that's the
basis on which we ultimately make our
decisions whether we realize it or not
but then if we're rational if we're
going to do ethics or moral theory right
we ought to make those central we got to
focus on for any given action or policy
what are the pleasures created what are
the pain scream so this is a hedonistic
type of ethics hedonism before this one
is going to be a little bit different
though one of the key things that
distinguishes utilitarianism from other
types of hedonism is that you're looking
at everybody's pain and pleasure so
we'll come back to that in just a moment
so let's think for a minute just about
pain and
pleasure when you engage in some sort of
action nowadays you're adults you've
lived a pretty long time by historical
standards you know you've managed a live
good portion of humanity do you have a
pretty good idea of whether the actions
you produce are going to cause pain or
pleasure in general do you ever get
surprised sure because you do you're not
God you can't predict everything it's
you
but what's something that's horrible to
drink that nobody likes well that thing
that makes you throw up dipa cat right
don't nobody likes that I think but if
you drink some poison you should
probably take some hip the cat if you
take it and it says on the bottle this
is going to induce vomiting any of you
like that
maybe you say well this is this is like
goo edited Saturday night this is what I
want to do then you know it's going to
cause you pain there's a high
probability is it 100% certain you could
be a meal you know but odds are that's
gonna happen think about other things
that you shouldn't you know mess around
with some of you may not be allergic the
way the rest of the human race generally
is to poison ivy maybe it doesn't affect
you most of you if you roll around
poison I do what's gonna happen to you
you can predict the consequences even if
you liked rolling around in it because
of the aesthetic pleasure or something
like that you're not gonna like it about
an hour later why not what's gonna
happen some very specific effects and
you're doing the gesture what's what's
getting at them you become very very
itchy and then the more you scratch the
more ditches and they eventually spread
it over your whole body yeah you get
blisters or you know it's no fun right
you've been putting the calamine lotion
on it's no fun I'm the other guy what
about pleasures are there a lot of
things that you know in your life that
are not necessarily guaranteed but
likely to
pleasure I mean those of you who have
like I do this one sort of coffee
I imagine you picked out what you did on
the basis then you actually like that
right you there are other things you
could have picked out that you don't
like so much that wouldn't before you as
much pleasure maybe some of them may
actually would have a bad taste and that
would give you pain we can understand
pain and pleasure two very broad terms
not always necessarily excruciating
physical pain any sort of trouble or
disturbance or irritation or bentham
actually says uneasiness would be a
matter of ultimately pain anything that
you think is good for you you think so
because it's pleasant if you like people
thinking well of you if you enjoy
spending time with friends from this
perspective you do so because of the
pleasure that you get if you like
getting in a class and getting an F in
the class feels bad to you the F is a
pain that he is a pleasure if you're you
know so motivated that even getting a C
counts for you the way that an athlete
for some other people well then you have
a different range of pain and maybe even
getting the a is not as much pleasures
it would be for somebody else right and
we have a lot of different kinds of
pains and pleasures and we could we
could explore this at great length we're
not going to but that's something that
you could think about doing on your own
time
you know actually sit down and think
sometime what are the things in my life
that give me pleasure what are the
things that give me pain in it well how
much and what kind and you may actually
come up with some things that's
surprising there may be some things you
write down and you think you're saying
well this is a pleasure and then the
more that you look at it the more you
start saying I don't actually like this
with people for example
you know I really like hanging out with
some of this up then you think back to
the last five times that you were
the person's painting I don't like being
with them or you know it could be the
opposite there are things that you
probably didn't like it one time and you
would like knee-jerk response throw it
to the pain section and if you think
about it actually you've kind of come to
like it it's become part of your routine
for example once you get finished here
with college many of you are now used to
a different routine of doing things once
you get finished a lot of the things
that seemed irritating and onerous to
you and you'll enjoy taking a break from
you will come to say you know actually I
kinda liked doing that that wasn't so
bad I can admit to actually somebody
signing something to read and reading
through it and getting something out of
it which may not happen in place unless
you're doing continual in education or
you're going on for your masters your
PhD
we're doing some sort of certification
so there's there's a lot of things that
we could analyze in terms of pain and
pleasure that them is going to introduce
another important term that is so what's
utility I mean if we're joking about
this you know lights cable we're not
talking about those kind of utilities
right
what is utility well it comes from an
old term and you could translate it
perhaps better as usefulness when
something has utility it has usefulness
useful for what well I mean what is the
utility of this let's take really basic
things what what is this good for you I
mean in a way it advertises Maris Dining
Services was that the main point of
putting this plastic in this form what's
the point of it what's its goal
yeah keep your popular oh yeah I mean
even more basically keep it all in one
place so I'm not walking around with it
in my hands like that and it does keep
it warm not as good as a thermos cup
with you but good enough for this it
allows me to walk into the cafe and
quickly fill up and them from the boss
and it's got you know why did why do I
need this kind of lid thing so I don't
spill coffee got my tie or my shirt
right I can close it up what I'm walking
what are these desks useful for these
are not good desks - right I don't have
a high degree of utility but they do it
at least one thing if you put your butt
down in that seat and your butt doesn't
stay there and you go down on the floor
the that's no longer a desk because you
need it for two things basically parking
your body and being able to support
things that you're you know typing out
or writing on or looking at or anything
like that right so that's utility we're
not getting at pleasure in pain we're
just talking about usefulness for
something now if you have this same sort
of general scheme let's let's actually
use this coffee cup again please this is
an example so we have a cup and the
purpose of the cup is to hold coffee I
know I could hold other things that we
use that for example why do I want to
hold coffee what's the point of that
well there could be more than one right
why do I need coffee
we've talked about this before because
I'm an addict I don't drink the coffee
I'm going to get headaches so could be
to you know hold the coffee so I can
kind of consume the coffee so I can wait
headaches any other reasons I
alertness well I mean I could just like
take caffeine pills for that I like
coffee
yeah like the taste that probably covers
the bases any other reasons they need to
think about him why somebody would pour
coffee in a cup and then bring it into
the classroom
babies are showing off but not much no
this one right I mean if we were like a
really status conscious society and
there was something besides Starbucks
across the way
that was like you know super high and
coffee had everything you know what this
would be and if you have any ideas like
you know some very exclusive cafe and I
want to show all of you how hip I am
that I could go over there and bring it
back and that's where the thing but
that's not not the case now so we'll
just stick with these three so now these
are all and these are all points reasons
for doing something avoiding in that X
what's it about
that's about winning team right I like
to taste well that's a matter of the
alertness can we understand that
immediately in terms of pleasure and
pain maybe not but could we analyze it
further why does it matter for me being
alarmed what do I get out of that
what do you get out of being alert a lot
of you drink coffee don't you in the
morning or tea here
anything like that what do you get out
of being alert I mean I suppose you
could say it's kind of a type of pain to
be groggy and not know where where you
are or what's going out to feel kind of
rundown when I have the coffee I
actually feel pretty pretty good so
maybe that that's also an interpreter
inflection
so you notice the usefulness ultimately
depends on pleasures of our pains of one
form or another
now Bentham says you can have positive
utility which is a propensity to produce
or to promote or to assure or however
you want to put it pleasure to a person
and then there's negative you say what
would negative utility be instead of
promoting pleasure of being producing
pain yeah very good
are there things that you can look at
and right off the bat know that even
though that thing by itself is not
necessarily painful you look at it here
and you associated how about things in
doctors offices are there any things
that you don't like about doctors
offices now I don't mean the waiting
room I mean the like you're in there and
butcher paper on the table
it's not exactly what your paper it's
something like it
they're unpleasant things about being in
the doctor's office for you guys I don't
what don't you like about the doctors
like this for the doctor hopefully
you're like if you go through a check-up
yeah you know I have weighed then I
don't go for check-ups I go when I'm
sick but yeah I mean it's no fun if
you're sick to be around other people
who are sick is it so that would be on
the pain balance what else don't you
like office you know give you a chance
those fun maybe like taking chest or
they're gonna draw blood or yeah that's
understandable
yeah I think that's probably one of the
biggest things taking pills isn't so bad
there's you know swallow and maybe
they're kind of being but yeah stressors
structure yeah yeah there's various
procedures like that you know stress
tests are no no picnic either if you're
not in shape you know because the whole
purpose is to try to get you close to
like a heart attack that doesn't feel
good especially if you're out of shape
so now if I just say doctor's office in
general now you probably associate that
with more pains than pleasures this is a
good example though because if you
analyze it further if that was all there
was the doctors then why would anyone go
to them other than masochist people who
enjoying the pain right hypochondriacs I
suppose why do you go to the doctor's
office why why do they like to do they
just enjoy poking you with the needles I
feel like that at first
why do they do all that stuff hopefully
you're actually gonna get better right
if not quit going because there's
there's no point over all going to the
doctor's office has a positive utility
if you map it out and you look at it in
the long term if you only look at it in
the short term it's got negative utility
it has more of a propensity to produce
pain there's a lot of things like that
where we can we can work them out and
balance out is this going to produce
more pain overall or is this going to
produce more pleasure overall and think
about this just for you don't bring
other people into it yet if you go to
the cafeteria what's let's let's come to
a consensus on your favorite food what
pick your favorite food Jenny or Shadow
doc really okay can the rest of the
class get behind it they like it
let's say you know all the different
different then they gave all the tippy
dipping sauces you want so any anything
you want it to taste like whatever you
know thing here you're into you know
ranch could be weird stuff like you know
chocolate what happened now how many
chicken fingers
can a person eat do you think probably a
lot right I mean if you're really hungry
and you go in and oh it's chicken
fingers today alright they like get you
a whole flight of dipping sauces I'll
try a bit of this little bit of this and
let's take it they just say I'm in we're
gonna keep them coming
it's not like the cat that's here here
we actually have to get up and walk over
and get some more and maybe they'll look
at your funny back didn't you Richard is
here instead they'll just keep bringing
it to your table so you can eat as much
as you want now that should be mostly
pleasure right
what's it like when you eat too much
all you've done that right then I don't
mean to cite people a little bit too
much way way too much like you just sit
there and eat and eat and eat and eat
and eat and then afterwards how do you
feel you just go to sleep that's not bad
disgusting did you think there may be
like yeah your stomach might actually
physically hurts because you crammed you
know if you can fast yeah oh that's yeah
you could if you eat too fast and you're
eating stuff like chicken fingers and
you don't chew it enough you can
actually like scratch your esophagus
well that wouldn't feel good either but
you know eating too much is that for
real think putting the you know 10
pounds of you don't want into a
five-pound bag and that doesn't feel too
hot so now ask yourself this if you were
to do that sort of thing which I'm sure
all of you have done at one time or
another which actually how weighs the
other do you end up feeling more
pleasure in the immediate thing than the
pain that you feel afterwards or do you
ultimately end up feeling more pain than
pleasure I mean if you were alternately
feeling more pain than pleasure than
pain then from utilitarian perspective
it might actually be rational go stuff
yourself but if you actually feel more
pain than pleasure that it's not
rational then that's something you
should avoid are there other things like
that you can think of where it feels
good in the immediate situation but then
the consequences the afterwards are more
painful what about losing the temper
what was it like when you lose your
temper and the other person who has got
it coming and you really lay into them
feels kind of good doesn't that lets say
they can't come into them for a long
time and you've kept your mouth shut for
a long time
put up with their stuff and now you're
actually going to tell them off doesn't
that feel good do you ever like go too
far with that anger seductive because it
does actually feel good the ancient
philosophers think they call actually
Homer called it sweeter than honey
dripping from the column in the Iliad
because anger has a tendency to do that
to us do you have you ever said anything
that you regret it afterwards and anger
to somebody else yeah
you ever do anything that couldn't be
fixed afterwards break something yeah
hit someone make a decision that can't
be undone say something that can't
really be taken back once you put it on
the table no here's something to ask
yourself did that cause you more pain in
the end that added pleasure probably
yeah
if you look at it that's what does one
know to make a segue into something else
as adjust your pains and pleasures that
are up for discussion that have utility
what about other people again from
utilitarian perspective other people's
pains and pleasures matter and how much
do they matter just as much as your own
now think about that angry if you can
angry at another person and you you
cross the line in certain respects maybe
they had a coming up to a certain point
and so you should have told them off you
should have done it in an emphatic way
and said you know you're you're not a
good person or something like that
something fairly innocuous you didn't
you know let's say instead you call them
a whole string of names names that
they're surprised to hear come out of
your mouth names that really hurt them
now you have some negative utility you
have some pain right because you feel
bad about it afterwards
maybe you regret losing control you also
did feel good to say those things right
that's pleasure what about the other
person is it a pleasant experience for
them for the most part is there any
pleasure some people enjoy getting other
people angry at them I don't know too
many people who really like that I'm not
quite sure why they like that either
that's kind of an interesting so I don't
know if any of you know they feel a lot
of pain so now if you bail it if you
look at the balance overall it looks
worse doesn't that quit other people be
affected by it
what if you're in like a public space
have you ever seen people fighting like
cats and dogs in a public space you
could have different reactions to that
did any of you get pleasure out of that
it could be funny depending on what
they're saying more often though how do
we feel I think that's yeah that's a
good way to put it uncomfortable we
might feel bad for one of the people you
know if we see the other person really
laying into them wow they should hang
out maybe we feel embarrassed or their
other but you get the idea if the more
you expanded certain things become more
painful overall and it's not just our
pains it's other people's pains too so
when we're calculating utility we want
to look at everybody's pains and
pleasures equally we want to give
everybody how would you put it we want
to take everybody into consideration as
if they matter just as much
so this is where utilitarianism is a bit
different than other kinds of hedonism
when we looked at hedonism before it was
about pain and pleasure and you could
actually use this notion of utility
usefulness
but you didn't worry so much about other
people you could worry about them in so
far as that affect you if it makes you
feel bad to hurt other people and that's
causing you pain right it makes you feel
good to help other people that's causing
you pleasure utilitarianism is saying
even if it doesn't make you feel good
and you create pleasure for somebody
else that's a good thing even if you
don't feel bad
afterwards it has no negative
repercussions for you but you create
pain for somebody else that's a bad
thing
and you could think about this in terms
of just human beings if you want to or
you could actually think about this in
broader terms animals you know we know
that animals can feel pain don't we we
certain animals I'm not sure how much
pain in the insect actually feels
compared to a higher animal like a cat
or a dog but you know your dog gets hurt
right how do you know what does it do to
life yeah cry that's it if you're you
know sometimes if you hurry it'll turn
around bite you it doesn't like letting
you down
can you tell me your dog's happy there
dying is pleasure how can you tell yeah
they're having tails they actually want
to be near you you can see sometimes in
there they're an expression they're not
like us you can tell can you tell me the
cat more or less
can you tell with a snake probably a lot
less
I mean speaks like some things they they
have pleasure okay do they have as much
as AIDS my source probably not as much
so what about a tarantula can you can
you tell it was pick at Rancho
right and actually fuzzy so we can might
be able to late to a little bit better
than other kind of insect they can feel
pain I think they can't feel something
or they're probably happy with their
eating things but do they feel the same
range of pain and pleasure as you
definitely not does your dog or your cat
I don't think so
so there's there's gradations